[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofran internacional y de France
24 nuestra última edición de este año
coincidiendo con las fiestas navideñas y
de fin de año por eso hemos decidido
hacer un balance de lo que nos deja la
actualidad en este 2022 para hacer el
balance me acompañan en este estudio
cuatro invitados les presento ya Pascal
Dúo analista Internacional corresponsal
del diario de hoy bienvenido Buenos días
Master en la escuela superior de
comercio de París y en asuntos globales
en la universidad de a ver si lo digo
bien sin jugar
Sandra javalera periodista independiente
bienvenida Buenos días y Matías
bienvenido muy buenos días el balance de
2022 hoy nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
2022 pasará la historia por la invasión
rusa de Ucrania la guerra de Putin y
toda la destrucción que ha causado sin
duda es la noticia del año que acaba que
acabamos ahora Y a partir de ahí bueno
pues todas sus derivadas ya las conocen
la crisis energética la inflación
etcétera Pero 2022 también nos deja otro
puñado de titulares con nombres propios
Empezando por la muerte de Isabel II el
giro sobre el aborto en Estados Unidos
las revueltas en Irán la vuelta de Lula
en Brasil la reelección de macron en
Francia la elección de Petro en Colombia
El tercer mandato para sijin pin en
China y las protestas contra las
políticas de cero covid o el mundial de
Qatar con el triunfo final de Argentina
añadamos a esto algunos asuntos que
continúan y se intensifican como los
fenómenos climáticos cada vez más
extremos o las llegadas dramáticas de
migrantes repasemos lo que nos deja este
2022 con algunas portadas diario El País
Putin lanza un ataque masivo contra
Ucrania Daily Express nuestra amada
reina muerto revista semana con la
elección de Petro en Colombia ABC Europa
respira con el claro Triunfo de macron
internacional Irán el régimen contra el
la nación Gloria eterna Argentina
campeón Bueno les quiero preguntar a
todos en general 2022 cuando leamos los
libros de historia que es lo que pondrá
en ese en ese renglón pues es un año
fundamental como muchos en la historia
la guerra definitivamente en Europa que
ha vuelto y sus consecuencias globales y
vemos bien que eso abrió una brecha en
el sistema que fuese geopolítico como
pues y lo ilustraste esta convulsión
internacional sin duda la guerra ha sido
yo diría claro lo fundamental el titular
fundamental Aunque claro que hay otros
que vamos a desarrollar en el programa
Bob con que se queda usted si eso
Totalmente de acuerdo con Pascal porque
la guerra igual para todo el mundo tanto
el occidente como el Oriente ha sido
algo conturbante y tal vez esa
perspectiva China para nosotros ha sido
un año de montaña rusas también primero
desde la política era de cero covid
luego con las protestas y ahora la
reapertura así veremos que
poco a poco una reintegración de china
en la arena internacional Sandra la está
la guerra también todas las derivadas de
la guerra que quizá como ciudadanos
occidentales A lo mejor hemos estado más
pendientes de lo que nos subían los
precios de la inflación de tal que a lo
mejor del último avance del ejército de
energía también la crisis energética de
cómo consumimos de cómo
estamos
rodeados de energía y bueno volvemos a
pensar no como debido a la guerra como
como estamos Cómo vivimos y además las
implicaciones políticas que esa crisis
energética esa inflación ha tenido en
procesos electorales no como los
partidos han tenido que adaptar las
campañas a un contexto de guerra Matías
Sí definitivamente la guerra Pues será
el tema más importante del 2022 estamos
hablando de las consecuencias Pero yo
creo que simplemente se nos ha olvidado
que son las consecuencias normales de
una guerra también enseñaron los límites
de un mundo globalizado pero esta guerra
yo creo que que será el tema más
importante del 2022 la guerra parece
puso distancia con la pandemia de la
covid hablaría de la pandemia es como
del jurásico pues no Aunque ahora mismo
estemos viviendo una Nueva Ola y en
China las cosas no mejoren y ahora lo
comentaremos con vos pero en cualquier
caso y tras 2022 y 2021 no sé si podemos
decir compañeros que este 2022 ya sí que
es un año entero de normalidad o lo de
lo que entendíamos como más o menos
normal
no estamos en la normalidad de
acostumbrarlos
pero
finalmente no lo que aparece es que la
covid aparece aún menos grave que la
guerra eso aparece y es por eso que Sí
definitivamente aparece clave ese 2022
tanto como lo fue 89 cuando cayó el muro
de Berlín como lo lo lo fue 45 etcétera
etcétera porque sí nos pone sobre la
mesa los temas del mundo de mañana que
fuesense cubrirá que fuese sobre los
temas de climáticos que fuese sobre los
temas ideológico lo vemos con lo que
está pasando en Irán bueno todo todo eso
está puesto Ya de relieve porque 2022 es
el momento en el cual el mundo está
dando vuelta hacia algo nuevo claro una
crisis que se desencadena con la
siguiente que es también lo que estamos
viendo con la comida y con la guerra Bob
en su país sin embargo la política de
cero covid ha provocado unas protestas
históricas y las autoridades han
reaccionado con un doble efecto
reprimiendo y flexibilizando al mismo
tiempo cómo está la situación con la que
acabamos el año el 2022 en términos en
China en China sí Yo diría que ahora
realmente como ven con el hemos ido casi
el víctima de nuestro propio éxito en
cierta manera con el control covid por
empezando Empezamos el año con casi unas
docenas de covid detectados diario y
ahora ya llegamos a recién cuando le
marqué a mi familia o sea literal todo
el mundo la mitad de la economía está
paralizada por la reapertura pero es
algo que la gente ya se esperaba por
mucho tiempo creo que con el rencor
contra la política del covid la gente ya
va acumulando un poco rencor Entonces si
veo que
es un tema bien sensible y finalmente
no es una situación
sostenible no porque
literal el resto del mundo ya se se iban
a reabriéndose y nosotros seguimos en
una esquina pero ahora veo que si
podemos tomar algo como la selección de
los otros países tal vez en uno o dos
meses ya regresemos a la normalidad se
ha criticado que no esté no estuviera
muy estructurada esa política de
reapertura de lo mismo que se criticó en
su momento que las campañas de
vacunación a la gente mayor si es cierto
yo creo que el gobierno chino sí tiene
un preocupación es muy válidas porque
según algún pronóstico si realmente
vamos a reabrir la economía por completo
Habrá más de uno de dos millones de
muertos ahora por la naturaleza del
tamaño del país luego por la baja tasa
de vacunación
pero luego la gente ahora se ha
enfrentado la decisión de si a qué costo
no la economía y luego vemos en lo que
pasó en urumuchi y en la fábrica de los
trabajadores inmigrantes y creo que
ahora ya la gente es realmente ya no
aguanta más y pide más No necesariamente
la democracia sino la libertad es un
programa de de resumen del año es por
eso que vamos saltando de un tema a otro
para hacer Digamos como como un fresco
no de lo que ha pasado en 2022 Sandra
Matías ustedes tienen la sensación de
que ha sido 2022 el primer año de la no
sé cómo llamarlo posnormalidad postcovid
o por llamarlo de alguna forma que
realmente han vivido con una normalidad
el año entero respecto a la pandemia
la palabra normalidad es muy subjetiva
porque según podemos hacer algo de
anormal algo normal Claro sin embargo sí
que es verdad que hemos intentado volver
a nuestras vidas de forma normal
no ir a trabajar irse de vacaciones ver
a la familia y demás sin embargo el
covid sigue ahí y es como nos hemos
adaptado a esta enfermedad Como cuando
alguien se adapta a saber que la gripe
existe y que bueno pues estamos enfermos
no vamos a trabajar o no vamos a ver a
la familia no pues estas medidas
yo creo eso es lo que yo he visto y que
hemos podido volver a la normalidad en
el día a día el titular de este 2022 y
no hubiera venido Putin con la invasión
Pero también es sorprendente como decía
Pascal como encadenamos crisis en estos
en este momento de la historia creo que
la guerra también dio otra prioridad
porque pues es verdad que sigue aquí el
covid pero es una nueva normalidad ya
que tenemos una respuesta que es la
vacuna pues la economía lo pedía la
gente lo pedía la sociedad en general
tocaba seguir viviendo ya que se veía
que sí se podía vivir y como lo decía
Sandra pues como con cualquier gripe
pues tocaba Pues cuando uno está enfermo
pues quedarse en casa y seguir viviendo
Porque de eso se trata hablando de
Ucrania la revista Time eligió como
vemos en su portada blodo mirt selensky
personaje del año 2022 les ha
sorprendido el
presidente ucraniano que se haya
revelado como ese gran estratega Matías
no no realmente no porque pues él lo
tenía muy fácil cuando empezó la guerra
le ofrecieron es de una cierta manera
pero decidió quedarse Pues porque yo
creo que que Ucrania es la clave del
mundo libre o sea él era todo un símbolo
y creo que pues obviamente por su pasado
de ser un actor pues lo hacía muy bien
es muy buen locutor y y creo que es el
mejor representante de su país lo hace
muy bien comunica muy bien y y
obviamente se ha vuelto todo un símbolo
para su pueblo porque toca recordar
también que antes de que empezara la
guerra él no tenía tan tan buena
popularidad porque había sido elegido
sobre un programa de anticorrupción y
pues no lo estaba cumpliendo tanto y se
volvió hoy en día un símbolo y los
ucranianos están lo apoyan están Detrás
de él si ustedes tuvieran que elegir en
esa portada de Time al personaje de 2022
Sandra usted hay que escogería yo estoy
más por más examino por toda la
revolución que ha entrado por los
derechos de la mujer pero también los
Derechos Humanos porque esto ha sido
como la gota que ha colmado el vaso para
mostrar que algo ocurre no en Oriente en
Irán pero también en otros países y que
hay que bueno hay que volver a ponerlas
a apretar las tuercas para poner las
cosas en respeto los Derechos Humanos
Pascal pues diría silensky porque
definitivamente
vemos además a raíz de la visita en
Washington esa cristalización
mítica del personaje Y cómo dijo Matías
usando la palabra de mundo libre está
muy ya poniéndonos en un momento clave
donde vamos a tener que escoger y el
tener que escoger va a condicionar el
mundo que que está llegando Entonces sí
creo que creo que Matías quiere destacar
a un compañero suyo referido Ucrania no
como personaje del año sí Yo quiero
recordar a mi compañero
que era camarógrafo en tv porque es todo
un símbolo obviamente no solo falleció
federick en ucranas en Ucrania siendo
periodista hubo muchos otros pero pues
representa la libertad la libertad de
informar y sobre todo el peligro el
peligro y la suerte que tenemos de vivir
en un mundo libre donde sí se puede
informar porque era un apasionado un
obrero de la información y también
sabían los riesgos que que podían pasar
muy brevemente su personaje de 2022
porque me tengo que ir a la pausa Sí yo
diría sería nuestro expresidente
changemy que recién falleció
la tradición de poder en el mandato
chino
pues vamos a hacer una breve pausa y en
unos instantes vamos a seguir hablando
de todo lo que nos deja 2022 y además a
la vuelta de pausa vamos a comentar las
tendencias que se van a sorprender para
2023 hasta ahora
soy Natalia Mendoza su corresponsal de
Franz 24 en Roma sigan conmigo todas las
noticias de Italia en nuestros
noticieros y en la programación diaria
Natalia Mendoza una de los 200
corresponsales de France 24 en el mundo
continuamos en Primera Plana esta semana
haciendo balance de 2022 en nuestro
último programa del año 2022 año
electoral especialmente intenso en
América Latina Pascal Bueno sobre todo
triunfos de la vuelta de Lula en Brasil
El Triunfo de Petro en Colombia que
destacaría del año electoral en América
Latina que ha sido efervescente Sí
definitivamente
diría alternancias políticas esos gritos
de los pueblos que llaman a justicia que
están cansados de todos esos disturbios
esas tensiones que quieren justicia
social lo vimos con la elección de Lula
lo vimos con Petro lo vimos lo estamos
viendo pues en Perú lo estamos viendo
este revuelto llamando Pues a eso ahora
ojo América Latina es un continente
diverso con el Caribe 33 países 33
realidades diferentes existe esa
Esperanza Pues de de una Unión regional
nueva gracias a esa esas convergencias
políticas pero también existen regímenes
muy autoritarios en Nicaragua Sí hay los
Ortega es decir pues que esa diversidad
está pero definitivamente 2022 en
América Latina las alternancias Y esa
esperanza de un nuevo nueva reactivación
regional en favor de la reactivación
económica aquí en Europa ha habido otros
dos nombres que han salido de procesos
electorales triunfadores el presidente
macron que fue reelegido el pasado mes
de abril y George meloni la
ultraderechista en Italia tenemos eso
triunfadores en proceso electorales en
el que estaría Lula en el que estaría
Petro el que estaría macron el que
estaría meloni a quienes destacarían
Matías Pues yo creo que la reelección de
macron fue muy natural o sea lo estamos
comentando pues ni siquiera nos dimos
cuenta porque no tenía competencia
tampoco o sea él él simplemente siguió
en el cargo Ahora sí las elecciones
legislativas que siguieron ahí dieron
una realidad un panorama más real de la
política francesa entonces recordemos
que las perdón a Matías recordemos a los
espectadores y oyentes Que a esas
legislativas los franceses quitaron la
mayoría rodillo la mayoría parlamentaria
a macron es decir lo que los franceses
votaron en cuatro rondas es si queremos
seguir con el presidente macron pero sin
una mayoría legislativa sí Cuál es la
elección de de esas elecciones pues
simplemente que el pueblo está muy
fragmentado al nivel político y que
quiere otra representación quizás
también están los límites de la de la
elección presidencial en Francia Sandra
este puñado de triunfaron de
triunfadores en carteles electorales A
quién destacaría
La Sensación Del nacionalismo sube en
Europa pero en el mundo entero y creo
que es una cuestión que hay que observar
para los años venideros porque la
derecha está Sandra derecha está
teniendo mucha presencia Aunque es una
ultraderecha también distinta no
a esa antieuropea de Víctor orban por
ejemplo no pero ya dos años consecutivos
han estado aquí en las elecciones en la
segunda ronda Así que yo creo que algo
ocurre en China tendríamos que destacar
Bob el tercer mandato para no igual es
algo que ya se esperaba casi en todos
los medios Así que no no vino una
sorpresa
cartel electoral como decíamos es otra
cosa sí de acuerdo pero todos modos
igual para mí fue sorprender a ver cómo
hasta en la asamblea nacional que
habíamos Si vemos los más altos los
personas de alto niveles hasta la gente
del lado más moderado ha sido sacada de
este mandato y es decir ahora el poder
se va cada vez concentrando en la mano
de una sola persona y luego también veo
por por un lado si él sigue teniendo la
popularidad entre la gente pero ahora
con la las políticas de cero covid
también se vuelve cada vez más
controversial
pero si el yo creo que la tendencia en
el futuro también desde esta protestas
que ha sido lo más grande desde
hemos también visto la eficiencia de
gobierno en controlar y censurar las
noticias en tiempo real
el techo cuando le marqué a mi familia
nadie se enteraba estaba consciente de
lo que estaba pasando es como las cosas
están pasando en un universo paralelo
interesante hay movimientos que
arrancaron en 2022 que se quedarán en
2022 y en cambio hay otros que tendrán
digamos su continuación en 2023 por
ejemplo Irán es un caso de un desenlace
para el cual Tendremos que esperar
todavía yo creo que estamos en una época
de revolución una guerra pero también de
muchas protestas de darse cuenta un
cambio de valores y de paradigmas
Entonces yo creo que Irán efectivamente
está está en este cambio y es posible
que en 2023 A lo mejor lleguen como dice
una boxeadora
iranina que vaya siendo tiempo que esté
Que bueno que lleguen al siglo XXI no
que lleguen
a los derechos humanos de nuevo en
cuanto al ciudadano a pie de calle
dirían que la inflación la subida de
precios ha sido la principal
preocupación de los ciudadanos Matías
Pues aquí en Francia cuando han hablado
el tema sí se habla mucho de este tema
obviamente porque es lo que te toca a
diario es decir cuando vas a hacer las
compras es una preocupación muy
importante pero a mí me sorprende mucho
porque todo el mundo aquí se acuerda de
los chalecos amarillos pues salieron a
la calle cuando la gasolina estaba dos
euros hoy en día está más de dos euros
los precios no paran de subir pero no
veo tampoco tanta gente en la calle
protestando es una preocupación
obviamente cuando hablas con la gente a
diario pero no siento tampoco que haya
una ola así de protesta pero a lo mejor
también eso no lo sé materias es porque
también el ciudadano es consciente de
que hay
está Putin que quiere jugar con la
opinión pública occidental a través de
ese arma y la gente identifica mejor el
origen de la inflación del mundo de lo
que está pasando Entonces a lo mejor eso
hace de contrapeso No lo sé No lo sé
pienso
estoy pensando Yo creo que hace parte de
un todo de una forma de desilusión
hablamos de en Francia una preocupación
es son los servicios públicos y eso sí
la gente lo tiene muy consciente pero a
la vez sabe que nos estamos integrando
en un momento clave de seguridad de
seguridad para todos y que podemos vivir
realmente de manera cotidiana A
diferencia de cambio climático que está
vigente definitivamente Pero eso cambia
tu vida cochera lo que está pasando en
Ucrania y la guerra con Rusia sí cambia
la vida cotidiana y lo vemos con el
riesgo en materia energética
con temas si vamos en África y van a
hablar de la crisis alimentaria yo me
recuerdo en makizal cuando fue en marzo
a lanzar un llamado internacional sobre
ese riesgo es decir pues esa conciencia
ya de de algo mucho más importante y nos
toca
también ya lo estamos esperando
experimentando las miradas en las vidas
cotidianas con canículas impresionantes
incendios que son es que ya está aquí es
algo que es algo que 2022 también lo
hemos visto que las lo que se deriva del
cambio climático ya lo experimentamos y
Seguiremos haciéndolo a nivel también de
agricultura porque quien dice cambio
climático dice
calores más intensos pero fríos más
intensos Mirad qué fríos están haciendo
ahora hoy en Estados Unidos están
hablando de una oleada de frío de menos
50 grados o sea está viendo una
desregularización total del clima y eso
va a influir en nuestra forma de vivir y
también de tener alimentos no de la
agricultura y de lo demás más cosas no
se estarán de acuerdo conmigo pero hay
si un país que ha dado titulares en este
2022 Ese ha sido Reino Unido no les
parece así el país que más titulares ha
dado en este 2022
Cómo ha encadenado la inestabilidad en
el gobierno los escándalos de Boris
Johnson
ese paso de listras que se acuerda de
listras ahora mismo ahora con sunat la
muerte de Isabel II los líos en la
familia Windsor de hecho han hecho una
serie en Netflix Los Príncipes no es
como bueno se está volviendo tendencia
esto de contar tu vida privada en la
siendo Rey o Sí Dentro de Netflix
iba a ser tan Movida en Reino Unido eh
Pascal pues definitivamente pero a la
vez es esa mezcla parece también una
telenovela un poquito de frivolidad
aunque no estamos pero necesitamos
ponen de su parte para
convertirlo en un poco no sé si te des
dramatizarlo Vos cómo ha visto lo que ha
pasado en Reino Unido
te acuerdas que había una época que
yo pediría la visa para entrar a Reino
Unido y Pero al final me llegó a la Visa
Después de tres mandatos de Primer
Ministro una reina y un rey nuevo Eso
quiere decir herramienta de tando
incertidumbre
respecto a la política ahí y también por
un otro lado yo creo que desde China si
ves la los medios estatales también la
gente es divierta un poco en Esta esta
este caos es como Guau que está pasando
no por ponerle un punto positivo a los
minutos finales de nuestro programa si
les preguntará por noticias positivas
que nos deja 2022 podrían recordar
alguna estos complementos hay que es
complicado el ejercicio alguna noticia
de 2022 positiva Matías no es una
noticia en Sí pero yo creo que
normalizar la manera de hablar del
cambio climático me ha parecido muy
bueno porque ya ya no se habla de un
loco que dice que el cambio climático
que yo que sé que se trata de aportar
soluciones y y me parece muy bien que ya
la gente se concientiza un poquito
acerca de este tema yo les doy también
otras ideas nuevos éxitos en la lucha
contra el cáncer el feminismo en las
protestas dirán o Europa que ha probado
por ejemplo un cargador único para todos
los dispositivos electrónicos que se
vendan en su territorio así no Tendremos
que estar bueno sí que ha habido alguna
cosa no Sí definitivamente Y eso ilustra
por ejemplo lo que sí lo que dijiste
ilustra esa voluntad de búsqueda de
Unión hacia un objetivo común y
destacaría justamente ese soplo para la
libertad de la juventud y eso lo vemos
en el mundo entero eso da mucha
confianza miremos a 2023 brevemente en
los últimos instantes del programa Les
comento algunas tendencias que van de
las que vamos a hablar en 2023 según un
artículo del diario El País a ver qué
les parece
el yoga o yoga para perros
Qué les parece tendencia 2023
la súper Apps todas las aplicaciones en
una sola concentrada y que en Asia ya
son muy populares
no sé si nos puede confirmar o no la
super Apps va a ser tendencia es lo que
ya existe aquí en China ahí
tenemos todo todo Está integrado Pero
puede ser interesante con
más tendencias las exploración como
tendencia no tanto las Apps sino la
búsqueda de información de la
experimentación sexual
la moda del Silencio cursos para buscar
los retiros que les parece vuelven los
cócteles sin alcohol y el minfuls
drinking y la explosión definitiva de
las dietas ecosostenibles bueno
Ya ven 2023 y el color que va a ser el
magenta Por cierto Muchísimas gracias a
los cuatro a todos ustedes que tengan un
feliz fin de año y Les esperamos aquí en
Primera Plana ya en 2023 ha sido un
placer Gracias muchas gracias gracias
[Música]